leave your intravenous already closed
welcome everyone to a new episode on the
why the greatest show on YouTube with
now over 93 million subscribers that's
right I'm recording now here because
Mart said sick everyone say much to get
the well soon in the comments you know
the thing about having no attention to
quality with your videos is that it
doesn't matter I can record this in a
bunker no one would care so here we are
let's jump into it what a week this has
been
we finally uploaded congratulations the
funny thing is with that song was that
we made it with the intention that
t-series were gonna pass us so we rushed
this video out so quickly
Joel flew in from LA stayed for like ten
hours we spent I don't know 12 14 hours
straight just filming the video and then
he flew back home and then it took four
months four teasers to pass so we had
all the time in the world to make this
video but I'm glad we finally got to
release it and it means we are winning
the battle so that's what I expect to
see a lot of means of today but I also
just wanted to say thanks for all the
support in the video I honestly didn't
know how it would be received with also
massive thanks to Rumi and Dave for
working on it and Jonas as well of
course everyone involved it's really
cool
I usually don't collaborate that much on
project so it was it was fun it's a
really fun project enough chitchat let's
jump into the memes oh god Oh Frick go
into forest in Japan entire fanbase you
didn't hit me when I went there until
afterwards I'm like wait go into a
forest surprisingly we made it out
no controversies controversy adverted
thank you very much Logan Paul for
taking one for the team now that Peter
pie is finally uploaded in his video
congratulation T series on winning we
should get him back to number one again
just to make things weird well that's
pretty much where we're at right now
400,000 away Jesus Christ
I guess I gotta make more songs huh damn
when maxing out one ability and forget
the rest all that's right t-series you
don't have a reddit that means they're
still winning
oh they're pointing out they have no one
on Twitter and they don't need it either
okay let's not let's get real here this
track number two question mark no it's
not a diss track
it's a congratulation video don't you
serious it's it's a diss track we
congratulation t-series or now that we
passed them isn't it congratulation me
congratulations PewDiePie top 10 anime
combat I mean it was pretty awesome I'm
not gonna lie I did not expect it to go
back there were like 200,000 away
how many nine-year-olds are there in the
world where are we finding the last ones
we should stop calling t-series t gay
gay people don't deserve to be compared
to such filth I think people should stop
calling T gay regardless it's like one
of those things where it's clearly just
an ironic insult but it wouldn't
surprise me if the media picks up on it
and goes like Opie PI's family they're
all Helmer phobic look they're calling
them T gay this is so awful
plus it's just kind of stupid I'd say
we'd call them T bad that's right that's
a real insult T bad you can't recover
from that t series is just about songs
and most of the songs are wait what is
this there's a new blue shirt kit I'm
sorry what
Asian boss did they do another one oh
damn in his nine-year-old RV reacts to C
Series are fasiq beautify oh I gotta
watch this I'll save it for later that's
awesome what's with Indian kids and blue
shirts what is happening what is the
power of the blue shirt 5 mil on YouTube
in 6 months never done before 30 minutes
we're so close to hundred guys we are so
close
pity pi I really hate football also
PewDiePie football PewDiePie is that a
Swedish football player oh it's a rugby
player well I'm down for rugby okay now
this would be epic okay wait what is
this
and pretty much you're watching let us
know you want to
one-on-one interview we'd love to get
your thoughts on the state of YouTube
and its relationship with independent
creators interesting I feel like I owe
them at least something for the amazing
video they did for anyone who is
wondering Peter pipes profile pic is
real from deadly man hi baby
there you go everyone great anime you
should check it out it's on Netflix I
really liked it and I liked the main
character even though he's not the main
character and I also really liked the
hand it's a very nice hand I just love
this picture cuz they clearly don't care
about making the art good it's
intentionally badly drawn which I can
really appreciate it's like a post anime
let's not forget these two people boy in
abandoned room he did an awesome job
that's what I said literally at the
beginning of the video get out of my
sight nothing but facts you know this
meme is going on me in review next and
you know it's not gonna be pretty
I'm sorry we need to poo but it's all
over for you am i right
the modern Wikipedia have to read if I
can't back again
how many times I've been changed it must
have been like five or six times that
that's crazy man
Republic attack the youtuber who had his
Legos stolen five months ago is back to
building can we give him a warm welcome
back check out Republic attack for being
back building Lego Star Wars attack sub
dad hit minus 100k no one is going to do
anything about it
Twitter bot signed off t-series have
been in the lead for 24 hours
Felix doesn't care anymore did we just
lose oh no oh no the media peopIe hates
Indian people 55 fans what about the
time he donated 246,000 towards Indian
charity the media did the past really
happen why do we have to bring out a
balanced view of a person when we can
just solely focus on the negative bids
why should the media be unbiased and
unpark it reminds me of the in the song
we have this line where it's like we
wanted to come up with the dumbest line
possibly you could make about someone to
not be offended and it's this one
[Music]
[Applause]
people are actually genuinely upset over
that line because they take it out of
context like Jesus Christ when is it
gonna stop just stop taking things out
of context what's the point
you just look stupid I just find it
funny because in Dave's video we're
literally like no one's gonna get mad
about that of course you can just take
it out of context so dumb the first and
last brofist is that is that my first
brofist did someone find the first I'm
telling you guys a hundred million the
5s brofist okay it's gonna take your
virginity
no okay nine year olds after drinking
the foam of their dad's beer I'm [ __ ]
faith
hey more lines to reference yay here's
one last brofist from the number one in
the world it's been an honor
I would always skip past this part when
I watch the video cuz I I just find it
so cringy but I'm glad a lot of people
got something emotional out of it at
least
yeah who would have thought the brofist
actually has so much emotional impact on
people the brofist has kind of become
like minecraft at this point it's
something that people used to do and
then it kind of became overly popular
and kind of cringy and then taken over
by kids and then now it's sort of
working its way back again to where it
actually has a stronger bond because you
associated with the certain nostalgia
it's just me or is that just what I
think
okay sometimes I put my mouse cursor
over Felix cursor and pretend we're
holding hands dude do what you got to do
I don't know what thing rode to a
hundred mill oh oh man one of you two
will do something a hundred mil that you
can't ignore a hundred mil right or can
you forgot about that it's actually
coming close when you realize that feud
is literally making music videos to
defeat him music company modern problems
require modern solutions that's right IQ
level infinite
shaking and crying right now pita pies
height 180 centimeters that's right
everybody reality can be what I just
googled 180 centimeters so I edited my
own page and I sourced myself and Google
accepted it so now I'm 180 centimeters I
hope that proves a point once and for
all that I am NOT the manlet okay I'm
very thought and I'm not insecure about
my height the war really ends when Flair
TVs livestream ends oh god no please
it's gonna go on forever I'm sure he
would love to keep it that way that's
good that's a good pewdiepie reply in
fact my feet are touching the ground oh
yeah so people are pointing out that I'm
wearing these plateaus shoes to make
myself look polar which I don't need to
because I'm already extremely tall and
perfect height so this is actually thank
you
someone made an accurate depiction of
what my faith proved me wrong okay this
is it Thank You King coz nice detective
work well done
spread the word you seemed captain
Marcia now and brace for the end game
let's do our part together on 29th of
April the 9th anniversary of PewDiePie
oh is it really
April 29 huh there will be free bar
brofist
on April 29 on April 29 everyone brofist
your favorite bro
okay that's coming I don't know if I
like that one I mean I loved it I'm
sorry I made a custom hundred million
trophy in 3d it'd be super cool if Felix
I yeah might be cool you could spin it
around and stuff I feel like it should
be like a nine nine year old related or
like something I don't know okay guys
that's it for this week's the way sorry
I couldn't be very loud I don't want to
get kicked out although we are leaving
tomorrow so I don't think it matters but
it's all about the respect in Japan
genuinely massive thanks for all the
support especially this week it's been
really amazing and I really really
really appreciate it
I'm going back soon so I'll see you back
in in UK
and see you that goodbye have fun and
remember to brofist tuber simulator it's
now so relevant that it's got a brand
new minigame crania drop the crane and
get fresh items only available in the
washing machine like game and you say
there's more of course there is new
knowledge perks new quests and new pics
links and legs guys lake